[Music]
hello everyone it's seven o'clock with
omicron cases surging across the country
multiple nhs trusts in england have
declared major incidents because of
staff shortages and the royal college of
nursing has called for the government to
take a more cautious approach on
restrictions
there are concerns about what could
happen with children going back to
school today and the return to work
after the christmas and new year holiday
we're going to speak to the vaccine
minister maggie through the shadow
education secretary bridget phillipson
as well as the nhs providers chris
hobson
also this morning we'll chat to the
chair of the government's vaccine
advisory committee and the director of
the oxford vaccine group professor sir
andrew holland exactly a year since the
astrazeneca jab was first rolled out
plus
[Music]
and the music medic who went from djing
and his scrubs in the kitchen to opening
london's new year's day parade and
supporting fat boy slim we'll speak to
nhs doctor dj kishan bedalia at around
half past nine it's tuesday the fourth
of january
as many as six nhs trusts declare
critical incidents as nurse leaders tell
the government the nhs can ill afford
the level of staff shortages caused by
omicron
back to school and back to masks
secondary school pupils in england will
wear face coverings in classrooms as
they head back today
i'm live here at victoria station in
central london where the omicron variant
is beginning to have a real impact on
staffing levels for rail companies
plus decision day the civil lawsuit
against prince andrew over allegations
of sexual assault reaches a crucial
moment in a new york court today
[Applause]
[Music]
starting the new year in the right way
the scott peter wright takes home the
darts world championship title
for the second time
[Music]
hello good morning multiple nhs trusts
across england have declared critical
incidents because of staff shortages
caused by the spread of the new omicron
variant the royal college of nursing has
written to the health secretary saying
that the nhs can ill afford the current
level of absences and urging a more
cautious approach to restrictions and
the concerns go beyond the nhs with more
than a million britons in self-isolation
as children go back to work and school
after the christmas holidays
well let's talk to our correspondent
tamara who's here with me in the studio
um a lot of pressure on the government
isn't there
with the pressure from the nhs and the
fact that these critical incidents have
been declared at a number of trusts plus
all of the children going back to school
in the next day or so absolutely and it
feels that the pressure unlike previous
waves is not because of huge numbers of
patients going to hospital although that
is ticking up all the time but because
of the sheer pressure of staff shortages
doctors and nurses being off with
covered people in social care being off
with covert so patients can't be
discharged and of course increasingly
teachers being off with covered meaning
children are being sent risk being sent
home from schools as soon as they get
back we're now seeing hospitals
declaring critical incidents we
understand they're around half a dozen
who have declared them internally
because of staff shortages taking out
one in 10 we think across the board but
in some trusts huge whole wards being
taken out by people having covered and
so that's where the pressure is coming
from now boris johnson made very clear
yesterday when he appeared a vaccine
center he didn't expect to introduce
more restrictions in england this week
the cabinet are meeting tomorrow and we
expect they're going to continue with
plan b which is working from home
mandatory masks on public transport and
indoors but not any more than that not
going as f as far as scotland wales and
northern ireland have the royal college
of nurses are now saying they should go
further but for so far the government
are holding firm and saying that despite
the pressure on hospitals they hope
things can continue as they are we'll
need to see whether all that mixing over
christmas the impact of schools going
back makes a difference in the coming
weeks okay we'll put some of those
points now
to maggie through she is the
parliamentary under state for vaccine
and public health uh vaccines minister
good to talk to you uh today maggie
troop uh let's just start with with
guessing some of the facts as how
they've emerged over christmas and new
year how many britons are currently in
self-isolation
i'm not sure of that actual figure but i
think what it's uh what's shown over
christmas is that a lot of people have
caught the disease that you know the
omnicom variant is very transmissible
but what is good news it doesn't seem to
be resulting in severe disease as some
of the other variants did so that is
really good news and obviously people
were taking precautions over christmas
and i'd like to thank them for that
you are the minister for public health
surely you should know how many people
are in self-isolation
well not everybody declares that they're
self-isolating i think that's one
important thing that it's something that
they do uh because of tested positive or
they've been in contact with somebody
who set it positive they don't have to
report that in but i think what has been
so clear over recent weeks is that the
vaccine is working and that's the best
way to stop the transmission and to stop
hospitalizations and for our life to get
back to normal
but in terms of of how we're going to
manage the nhs in coming days in terms
of how we're going to manage schools and
and even workplaces
how can the government do that if it
doesn't know how many people are
self-isolating when we know the latest
figures about positive tests for example
but you know over a million positive
tests that that means the people that
they know the people that they live with
will also have to self-isolate doesn't
it so we could be looking at or five
million people potentially or even more
you just don't know
well i think the important thing is that
we are looking at the data all the time
with regards to hospitalizations as you
say people who have actually tested
positive and also the number of people
in the uh the high dependency units as
well i think at the moment if you look
at people have been hospitalized then
they are going in with less severe
conditions than before and the numbers
that are in hospital beds is about half
what it was a year ago and that just
shows the power of the vaccine and my
message today is if you haven't come
forward through your booster yet come
forward if you haven't had your first
dose of vaccine or delayed your second
dose that there's always chance to come
forward to get those
life-saving vaccines it's never too late
and that offer is always open well we'll
come on to the nhs in a moment but it on
the subject of vaccines there were
around two million booster appointments
that have yet been taken we know that a
lot of booster centers are even open on
christmas day um
is this that people are not bothering to
get their booster or have they got a
booked appointment
and they they've then gone to a walk-in
center and got it separately why do you
think there are so many appointments
that are are being missed for boosters
i'm not sure about it's being missed but
we did open up the national booking
service so people could come along and
get a vaccine when they went when they
booked the vaccine or the walking
centers as well and they were hugely
hugely popular before christmas and you
know so many people took up that offer
over 34 million there are two million
vaccine appointments available this week
um you know
you're desperate physical to get
vaccines why why are all these
appointments available
well it's quite right that we have those
opportunities there for people to come
forward to get their booster be wrong of
us if we should shut down the national
booking service and just expected people
to go into walk-ins it's quite right
that offer is there for people to book
their vaccine whether it's their boosted
dose or as i said their first dose or
second dose that offer is always open
and it's quite right that across the
country people can make their uh their
appointment and come forward for their
vaccine but in terms of numbers only 100
000 were boosted yesterday so the
numbers have really declined haven't
they
i think we've just been through two
weekends of bank holiday and i think
that's quite clear that numbers will
change as we move forward and what was
really incredible is the number of
people coming forward on christmas day
and even on the bank holidays we had
more people coming forward on the bank
holidays than other bank holidays in the
past so people have really taken the
vaccine program to heart and it's
probably the most successful vaccine
program that the nhs has ever run and
probably one of the most successful
across the whole world as well and i
want to thank everybody for playing
their part whether it's the nhs the
thousands millions of volunteers that
have really helped made a difference and
people coming forward to get that that
life-saving vaccine in such a timely way
nevertheless we're seeing critical
incidents at a number of hospitals um
how how many exactly uh how many we
think about half a dozen nhs trusts have
had critical incidents because of staff
shortages how many exactly do you know
i think you the critical incidents are
announced and then there can be very
short
term ones uh and it's saying to the
other trusts around you know can we have
some extra help can we have the mutual
aid sometimes it's just a matter of
hours that the critical instance in
place for other times it's longer but
it's actually reaching out to the the
wider nhs to say yeah we have got a
problem in this particular area and it
is sometimes quite geographical as well
and for different reasons it could be
staff shortages it could be other
reasons so it's quite wrong do you know
how many tests you know how many were
out this morning for example i know as
you say it is fast moving but
you know what are the latest figures
from this morning
well it is fast moving that's why it'd
be wrong of me to actually
say a number because you know quite
shortly there could be another one or
another trust could actually say no
we're back on track now and we're okay
and it's a mechanism that's been put in
place in the past and yeah i'm sure is
it sorry but is it is it wrong wrong for
you to say we wouldn't want you to
mislead but you know it strikes me that
perhaps you just don't know
to be to be honest i haven't had an
update this morning as we know the uh
lincolnshire hospital trust declared one
yesterday others have declared them in
the past and i think as i've said it can
be very short-lived and
and it can be longer as well but it's
for different reasons sometimes it's
staff shortages sometimes it's bed
capacity it's complete mixture and it's
quite right you're the minister of
vaccines
you're the minister for vaccines and
public health the government has put you
up today to talk to us about covert to
talk about the pressure on the nhs and
to reflect on the last 12 months of the
astrazeneca vaccine but
surely in that case you should know how
many nhs trusts are in critical measures
at the moment and indeed how many people
in the uk are self-isolated they seem to
be
really key bits of data that the public
want to know they want to know how many
people are self-isolating they want to
know if their local hospital trust is in
a critical condition or not does the
government have a handle on this
it definitely does and obviously there's
meetings on a very very well on a daily
basis with the key people in within nhs
england and they've been updated later
on on that situation but as i've said
that you know the best thing to do to
help to protect the nhs and to make sure
that other major uh uh infrastructure
can continue is people to come forward
for their vaccines as you say it's
actually just a year today since the uh
brian pinker had that first oxford
astrocenic
vaccine out of clinical trials and
that's a real good milestone and it's an
amazing achievement for british research
and innovation that since then over 50
million of those doses of the
uh astrazeneca vaccine has been put into
arms in the uk
and 2.5 billion doses across the world
have been administers of that particular
vaccine and it's testament to the work
that's gone on within the uk
absolutely and nobody wants to to take
away from that but but equally we also
have to to look at the current
situations we have it now not the
situation over the last 12 months and
the royal college of nursing have called
on sajid jabba to work with counterparts
across government for a more cautious
approach in england
um the the rcns also said it's concerned
about the fact that there are different
regulations in different parts
of the uk nations we're hearing about
pressure on maternity
departments we know that some hospitals
in the north are now not allowing
visitors again it
it does seem that the messaging that's
coming from the health service is that
the government needs to be doing more
is the government listening is the
government prepared to bring in more
restrictions
look as the prime minister said
yesterday that we have got plan b which
is people working from home
the the kovid pass
face coverings and obviously the vaccine
program which is so so important and
these are all important but if they're
not working if we have six trusts in
critical measures then it suggests that
the plan b possibly isn't as effective
as it might be and that do we need to be
looking at plan in
that plan b is working
as you can see from the number of
hospitalizations it's far far fewer than
this time last year and that's so
important as well that the vaccines are
working the measures for people to work
from home are working and we you know
people are being really really compliant
it's really good news that people want
to do their uh part to make sure that we
get this virus under control and you
know the prime minister said that you
know plan b is working there'll be a
cabinet meeting today and you know i
don't see any reason why we need to
change it's important that we do follow
the data we've done that all along and
we'll continue to do that and you know
people are playing their part and i want
to thank them for that
you're talking about the vaccines and
how important they are um
why are we then selling off at a uk
vaccine development center near oxford
the the vaccine manufacturing and
innovation center i mean that doesn't
seem like a
great confidence boost does it that if
we are selling off these facilities as
soon as they appear successful
well i wouldn't want to comment on the
commercial decision but i think what is
important that we've got um good supply
of vaccines you know we've we've got the
the fires in the modern astrazeneca and
others coming online as well and it's
important that people do come forward uh
for those first vaccines and the second
one as well
that offer is always open and i think
what was really encouraging as well was
as the booster program
was turbocharged more people came
forward for their first dose as well i
think they've seen just how important it
is they've seen other people get the
vaccine and they've also sadly heard the
people say that they've been seriously
ill because they haven't well they
haven't had the vaccine and to put that
message out that vaccines are important
that do as save people from getting
serious disease and they do save lives
yeah despite that we still have six
trusts and critical incidents um maggie
through parliamentary under secretary of
state for vaccines and public health
thank you very much
thank you thanks
well let's take a look now at the latest
covert data 157
758 new cases were reported in england
and scotland in the latest 24-hour
period 42 deaths were recorded in
england bringing the total number of
deaths within 28 days of a positive test
across the uk to
eight hundred 148
ninety three
well those high numbers of omicron cases
is also impacting the railways the staff
forced to isolate and train services
in turn being cancelled at sky's ender
braided joins me now from victoria
station in central london hi ender so
you've managed to avoid covert over
christmas you've not seen necessarily
all in nearest and dearest you're back
to work today and then you find out the
trains don't work
yes the train companies are really
really struggling all because of culvert
and the rise of the omicron variant so
it's having a huge impact on staffing
levels the information i have is that
staff absence is running at 9.9 percent
across the industry over the past two
weeks of the festive season so touching
ten percent of staff out omicron is
having a massive massive impact and the
end result is train companies are having
to collapse their timetables run reduce
schedules there are some short-term
cancellations in place as well now we've
spoken to the rail delivery group and
they say to just bear with the train
companies they're doing their best
they're putting in place measures that
are designed to give people some sort of
you know access and confidence in the
system they're urging people to get
online so they can see what trains are
being canceled but here at london
victoria it is probably the quietest
i've ever seen it in this week of the
year there's hardly anyone inside very
very few trains running southern rail
have stopped all of their services in
and out of london victoria until the
10th of january and that is as a direct
result of staff absences so the gatwick
express for example not running from
here either so a very tricky period for
the rail industry staff absence is now
running at 9.9 percent
tricky indeed ender thanks very much
well later in the program we're going to
talk to the shadow education secretary
bridget phillips about today's return to
school
and at five past eight this morning
we'll talk to the government's chair of
the vaccine advisory committee and
director of the oxford vaccine group
professor andrew pollard as we mark one
year since the astro at zenika jab was
first rolled out
[Music]
and then ahead at half past eight i'm
going to talk to the chief executive of
the nhs providers and also a covert 19
intensive care unit anesthetist
about the current staffing pressures on
the health centers
lawyers for prince andrew will today
call on a judge in the u.s to throw out
the sexual assault case he's facing the
case has been bought by virginia dufrey
and a legal document made public
yesterday shows that she entered into a
settlement agreement with jeffrey
epstein which the duke of york's lawyers
claim also covers him it's up to the
judge to decide whether he should be
immune from liability sky's joe pike
reports now from new york
among prince andrew's close friends a
child sex trafficker and a prolific
pedophile
the duke of york traveled on jeffrey
epstein's private jet and mr epstein and
gelane maxwell were invited to balmoral
and windsor castle
but it's the accusation prince andrew
sexually assaulted virginia dufrey three
times when she was 17 years old that is
at the heart of this case he denies
wrongdoing
he knows exactly what he's done and
i hope he comes clean about it thank you
the secret document shows jeffrey
epstein paid virginia du frey
500 thousand dollars in a 2009
settlement there is no mention of prince
andrew however it includes a clause
which says virginia frey does release
acquit satisfy and discharge any other
potential defendants from all and all
manner of action
now this is the clause which prince
andrews lawyers are likely to argue
means the whole case should now be
thrown out virginia dufrese team say
this document is irrelevant and the fact
that the prince isn't even mentioned
means he's not covered by it ultimately
it's up to the judge to decide if this
case should go ahead but if it does
expect a full civil trial in the autumn
in civil cases parties usually settle
before that happens
but some legal experts think one of the
parties in this case may be loath to do
that
virginia is already a multi-millionaire
because she was able to settle against
epstein's estate so there's less
pressure on her to take a settlement and
make the case disappear she's not as
needy as she might have been several
years ago in that sense this is the sort
of case where
virginia herself and her lawyers might
say to prince andrew we don't care how
much you pay we're not settling we want
the truth to be told we want to have a
trial
the next hearing in this case takes
place later today tarnishing the start
of the queen's platinum jubilee year and
raising further questions about the
judgment of the man said to be her
favorite son joe pike sky news new york
meanwhile one of america's most
high-profile investigators is demanding
that donald trump and his two eldest
children give evidence in an
investigation into his business empire
new york's attorney general issued the
subpoena the former president's lawyer
called it a political witch-hunt the
trump family has asked the court to stop
the action our u.s correspondent greg
milam has more it's it's certainly the
most significant moment in in an
investigation has gone on for three
years now this this subpoena for donald
trump and two of his children
by the attorney general would ask for
them to be interviewed uh under oath and
of course donald jr and ivanka were key
to the running of the trump organization
particularly when their father was in
the white house the indication is they
won't comply with this
this subpoena so the chance they could
be held in in contempt of court so
there's a long way to go in this the the
central allegation that this
investigation is looking at is this
claim that the trump organization would
inflate the value of its properties and
its assets when it was trying to borrow
money against them and then deflate
those values when they were filling in
the tax return uh it is a civil case
lots of documents handed over already we
know there's been this battle over
donald trump's personal tax return
that's part of it as well there is a
criminal case too that the trump
organization has denied these
allegations in fact they filed a lawsuit
to stop this investigation from going
ahead they say it's politically
motivated they've called it a witch hunt
which of course is familiar because
aside from the business there's all the
politics and and this is the week when
america will look back on january the
sixth last year in that attack on
congress and donald trump planning to
hold a news conference on the
anniversary on on thursday to put his
side once again of of that story so a
new year but but familiar old themes for
donald trump
let's take a look at some other stories
making the news this morning and the
founder of a failed silicon valley
startup that promised to revolutionize
health care has been found guilty of
fraud in california prosecutors argued
that fairness founder elizabeth holmes
lied to investors by claiming that her
company's technology could detect
diseases from just a few drops of blood
well the former billionaire denied the
charges but now faces up to 80 years in
prison
the brazilian president jab
bolsonaro has been admitted to hospital
with what is thought to be an intestinal
obstruction which could require surgery
according to his medical team the
hospital said his condition is improving
the brazilian's been hospitalized
several times for similar problems since
being stabbed in the abdomen during a
campaign rally in 2018.
charities are calling on the government
to open more safe routes to people
seeking asylum in the uk after data
showed the number of people making
dangerous journeys across the channel in
flimsy inflatable boats travelled last
year
more than 28 300 people were known to
have crossed the channel in 2021
according to the press association news
agency
private parking companies are handing
out an average of more than 22 000
tickets every day to drivers analysis of
government data shows four million
tickets were issued to british motorists
between april and september despite a
reduction in cars on the road due to the
pandemic
and it's been a festive three weeks at
the world darts championships fans have
turned up at alexandra palace in london
and fancy dress and good voice ready to
party and it all came to a noisy and
exciting climax last night as peter
wright took home the title in a
thrilling final against michael smith
sky's kamali melbourne reports
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
is the champion
this is the moment that peter wright
claimed glory in front of hundreds of
fanatical fans at the new home of darts
alexandra palace in london
[Applause]
the world number two known to his fans
as snake bite bested his rival bully boy
michael smith to claim his second title
it's not about me it's about the future
of arts and this man
he let me in tonight i i just love him
but so i feel so
bad because i know
as soon as he gets a major it will just
trounce everybody
and you will
the 51-year-old scotsman with the mohawk
and snake tattoo joins phil taylor john
part adrian lewis gary anderson and
michael van german as a multiple title
holder
emotional end to three weeks of
competition
time now for wife joanne the new trophy
and the half the million pound prize
money
i'm going to be speaking to peter right
before the end of the show hopefully so
stay tuned for that
right let's get a quick look at the
weather
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather
sponsored by qatar airways
a stiff northerly wind will make it cold
today it's mostly clear dry and cold now
with icy stretches in the north but
there are wintry showers near north
facing coasts southern england more
general patchy rain cloud and rain
mostly clear from the northwest during
the morning
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
now if you think it's chilly out there
take a look at this
a winter snow storm brought heavy snow
to washington dc affecting everyone from
the president
to also some pandas apparently show us
the pandas
there they are
yeah
love a panda it's almost camouflaged if
it stands very still next to the tree
around 10 inches of snow was forecast
which closed schools government offices
and even grounded the president's
helicopter as he left air force one
returning to washington after a week in
delaware but some appeared to enjoy the
weather these pandas are at the
smithsonian zoo and they did seem quite
happy don't they wandering across the
frozen ground
sure they've still got some bamboo
now
coming up the latest as schools across
the country head back to the classroom
with new covert 19 measures in place
[Music]
welcome back you're watching sky news
breakfast we're talking a lot about
omicron and schools and the health
service this morning uh let's bring in
tamara cohen our political correspondent
who's with me now and we spoke to the
vaccines minister one of the vaccines
ministers earlier in the program wasn't
able to give us a lot of answers
about
the numbers of infection across the uk
that's right so we know that there are
um well over a hundred thousand positive
tests a day at the moment but that's
been a bit disrupted over christmas with
some parts of the uk not reporting them
and they could of course be far higher
with people not getting tested the
vaccines minister couldn't tell us how
many people might be in isolation of
course it looks like it's probably over
a million if everybody who's got it is
in isolation for at least seven days um
their contacts no longer need to isolate
unless they're unvaccinated in which
case they do so how high it is she
couldn't tell us the government are
working on the basis of potentially a
fifth or a quarter of staff being off
with covid in the coming weeks when they
look at the nhs and schools and but this
is what maggie through told us earlier
i'm not sure of that actual figure but i
think what is what's shown over
christmas is that a lot of people
have caught the disease that you know
the omnicom variant is very
transmissible but what is good news it
doesn't seem resulting in a severe
disease as some of the other variants
did you know how many we're at this
morning for example i know as you say it
is fast moving but
you know what are the latest figures
from this morning
well it is fast moving that's why it'd
be wrong of me to actually
say a number because you know quite
shortly there could be another one or
another trust could actually say no
we're back on track now and we're okay
and it's a mechanism that's been put in
place in the past and yeah i'm sure is
it is it sorry but is it wrong wrong for
you to say i mean we wouldn't want you
to mislead but you know it strikes me
that perhaps you just don't know
to be honest i haven't had an update
this morning as we know the uh
lincolnshire hospital trust declared one
yesterday and those have declared them
in the past and i think as i've said it
can be very short-lived
well of course many questions for uh the
education world as well the joint
general secretary of the national
education union mary bastard joins me
now um in terms of the advice that
teachers and schools have been given
from the government is it clear enough
well it is clear um the advice is clear
the the
problem is it was issued three days ago
and it's you know i don't i simply don't
understand why advice which schools have
to adopt needs to be issued so late it's
yet another case of the government just
being last minute about guidance which
she could easily have issued earlier to
give schools more time to prepare but
the advice is clear um children will if
you're a secondary school people you'll
be taking two lateral flow tests this
week you will be required to wear masks
in the corridors and in classrooms and
so that advice is clear
we would also say that the vaccination
rate for second for secondary pupils is
less than half pupils have had their
first dose and that is another important
measure in order to keep um uh covered
suppression uh as low as possible the
expression of the transmission of the
virus as low as possible in schools
how well equipped are schools to deal
with absences we don't know what level
absences may be but but what impact do
you think it could have
well i think it could be significant in
december
that's the latest month for which we
have figures eight percent of um
education staff were absent because of
covid and that was with a mixture of
delta and omicron so a you know a less
potent mix for transmission um i think
that with omicron with the fact
particularly in primary schools where
in december primary pupils where the age
group which had the highest rates of
infection i think that um
you know there is a possibility that
staff will
become sick and education staff are more
likely than any other profession they
catch the virus 37
according to the office of national
statistics more likely to catch covid so
if they do that and they have to be at
home then there will be the issue about
who will be taking classes and that's a
real problem because we know the one
thing that we want to happen is for
schools to be open and children and
young people to be educated in school
because that's the best place for them
so it is a shame that the government
hasn't done more to ensure that that is
going to happen
are schools facing pushback from pupils
over mosques i mean i'm imagining a lot
of teenagers will spend a large part of
the last couple of weeks not wearing a
mask in daily life and they're now
having to go back to wearing them day in
day out are there a lot of arguments in
classrooms about these things
i'm not hearing that i mean they're used
to wearing them secondary school people
are used to wearing them in corridors
and
you know um
communal places in wales and scotland
they've never stopped wearing masks
throughout the day so no i'm not hearing
that there's widespread um revolts
against that i think that most teenagers
are sensible
are quite resilient and understand that
this is a measure that is necessary the
mental health effects
of not being in school are far greater
than wearing a mask if american musk is
a price to pay but staying in school
continue to be educated continuing to be
learning with your friends continue to
socialize continuing to have a place to
go if you've got if you've got free
school meals continue to get that
preschool meal if you've got
um worries and troubles in your life
having the school is a place where
you've got people to talk to who will be
able to help you all those things all
the benefits of being in school and
schools remaining open are far greater
than the disadvantage of wearing a mask
the two just don't compute
okay doctor marybell said the adjoint
general secretary the national education
union thanks a lot for joining us thank
you
let's cross to our correspondent becky
cottrell who is at a secondary school in
sheffield for us
is she there
yeah i hope so
i can hear you i just can't see it uh
becky uh tell us what they what they're
getting up to there what are they doing
in terms of pre-testing for the kids
coming back
yeah today obviously is the day they
test children before they return to the
classroom tomorrow there's around a
thousand children that need to be tested
today i don't know if you can see me yet
or just hear me but there are testing
bays set up ready for that it takes
about an hour to work through each year
group and that's why they need all day
to do it now the head teacher told me
that they were prepared for this they
knew before they broke up for christmas
that they would have to test on site
today and they've got a mixture of staff
and then specially trained testers that
have brought been brought in to help he
also told me that supply of tests is
pretty good obviously there have been
national shortages of tests but at this
school they've got enough not only to do
the tests on site today but then to give
kids those tests to take home obviously
children now have to do tests twice
weekly at home
another new thing nationally today as
i'm sure you've been talking about is
the wearing of masks in the classroom
for secondary school students now here
they'd already been doing that that was
something that was brought in across the
sheffield region before christmas so
children know what they're in for and
those measures will be in place until at
least the 26th of january now another
thing that i asked the teacher about is
staff shortages he said thankfully
they've only had a couple of support
staff calling sick saying they have to
isolate but obviously the concern here
and for countries across the country is
that as the children return cases could
rise and that could take out a lot of
teachers now this school is ready and
willing to merge classes if necessary
but i asked the head teacher about the
idea of bringing in supply staff or
getting retired teachers to return and
he said look it's really hard to get
hold of supply staff at the moment and
the idea of retired teachers returning
just isn't that realistic
okay becky thanks very much glad that we
could see you eventually uh and let's
talk now to a headteacher of a school in
rotherham to see how that all fits in
with what his experience is pepe diazio
i'd love to talk to you today um mr
diazio how do you feel about schools
coming back today and the kids coming
back do you feel optimistic or are you a
bit worried
i think as a head teacher we're born to
be optimistic i think the phrase that
we're using at the moment is that we are
hoping for the best and planning for the
worst so the unknowns as people have
said earlier in your show are around the
number of cases that we'll meet this
morning and what we've got to do is make
sure that we're ready with a number of
different plans to make sure that staff
are prepared to help cover
other classes that may not have their
colleagues in them so that we can keep
students in their classes this next term
what's your latest knowledge about um
teachers do you know you have a clear
idea of how many teachers are coming in
and how many can't
well i have to say it's better than it
was in november and december
we've had just two colleagues ringing
this morning who tested positively last
night and so we're aware that they won't
be in for the next seven days at least
we were facing absences of around 9 or
10
in december and so that was definitely
something that we struggled with
we had colleagues who were taking
multiple classes together in large areas
such as such as the main hall what we're
hoping for over the next few weeks is
that we don't see those sort of numbers
away however uh what what we do know is
that this is something that's beyond our
control at the moment
that's really positive isn't it you know
if it has really got seemed to got
better for you
at least up to now i don't want to jinx
things
you were talking about teaching children
in larger groups um
is that really a workable solution in
the long term because some people say
have suggested the department for
education suggested that can work but
other people have said it it can become
a bit mad max like if you are teaching
huge numbers of teenagers all together
yeah i don't think it's a long-term
solution but i think it's a better
solution than moving to virtual learning
and remote learning i think for a
short-term basis if you can have a
specialist science teacher who's a
senior and experienced teacher taking
perhaps two or three groups of up to 40
or 50 students in a larger space it does
mean you've got to adapt your curriculum
but one of the plans that we have in
place is to do just that just those
adaptations to make sure that we can
cover for those eventualities should
they occur
and what about things like masks access
to masks and access to these ventilation
units that the government was talking
about at the weekend are you happy that
you've got all the equipment you need
i wouldn't say that we're happy i
understand that there are 7 000 air
purifying units that are available as i
understand it there is something like
over 300 000 classrooms across the
country that would benefit from having
those units i'm sure that over the
coming weeks you know i'm sat here today
in an office with my windows open the
weather's quite pleasant here in
yorkshire today however in the coming
weeks it's going to get colder and i
know that our staff and our students
would benefit from having
better air purifying units and we're
going to need more than the 7 000 that
have been initially ordered from the dfe
and in terms of mass squaring um mary
bowster we just spoke to from national
education and said she'd not heard
anything about teenagers objecting
swearing masks in schools what's been
your experience have they all been
pretty compliant
yeah we've had maths all through the
autumn term uh the addition uh today as
we come back is that they'll be wearing
of masks during the classroom sessions
as well it's not great for learning
particularly in language lessons for
example where students need to speak
more often it certainly isn't great for
teachers who need to have
their voices and and faces seen a lot as
part of their uh teaching of a lesson
but it's one of those things that i
think the whole country's becoming used
to and it's just part of the daily life
in schools at the moment really
does it have any impact on behavior
are they more mischievous when they're
able to hide behind a mask perhaps or
again is that not really born out well
no i i do think it is we read so much
from people's faces and so that that is
an integral part of being a teacher and
it is more difficult to understand what
a student is thinking if or anyone is
thinking with that with a mask on but
what i will say is that students
understand the importance of keeping
each other safe many of them have got
family and relatives who are shielding
at home and what we've seen is that
students really want to help support the
community and make sure that they help
keep our community safe
and i suppose in terms of being at
school and being with their friends it's
in their interests as well isn't it for
this to work for everybody
absolutely i mean if you talk to our
students that they will say that they
hated lockdown that the biggest part of
lockdown for them and covid was missing
their friends and not having the
opportunity to socialize uh you know the
school days are the best days of our
lives and our students want to make sure
that they're here and enjoying school
and part of that will be the return to
school today we're testing over 600
students today and they'll be our senior
students in school and the younger
students will return over the next
couple of days and i know that many of
them can't wait to be back here and
we'll love seeing them again
and in terms of what more the government
could be doing if the government
ministers were watching on at the moment
and you have a wish list what would you
ask them to do to make the next few
weeks uh smooth for you and your pupils
well we've been promised to review at
the end of the month around math
squaring and what i would ask is that we
would welcome earlier notification of
any plans uh to hear these plans in the
sunday papers as we did this weekend was
certainly wasn't something we'd welcome
and and i think all head teachers would
prepare would prefer to have more
leading time so that they can plan for
what's happening over the coming weeks
what the government are doing right now
with the exception of the extra air
purifying units is certainly a welcome
step forward compared to where we were
last year
pepe diazio head teacher at the wales
high school in rotherham lovely to talk
to you this morning best of luck getting
them all back today hope all those shoes
have been shined
and those curls
and fringes tamed thanks a lot
including yourself
now let's take a look at this story
15 minutes was all it took for these
twins in california to be born in
different years
alfredo was delivered on new year's eve
at 11 45 while his sister aylin was born
at midnight on new year's day do we know
which was which alan wade
five pounds 14 ounces her big brother
alfredo maybe he's the one on the left
uh weighed six pounds one ounce i'm just
guessing though who knows um lovely
story though still to come on sky news
breakfast
lawyers for prince andrew will today
call on a u.s judge to throw out the
sexual assault case against him we'll
have the very latest
[Music]
prince andrew's lawyers will today call
on a u.s judge to throw out the sexual
assault case brought against him by
virginia dufresne well a legal document
made public yesterday shows that mr frey
entered into a settlement agreement with
jeffrey epstein the prince's lawyers
claim that it covers the duke of york
too
well with me now is the legal
commentator joshua rosenberg and joshua
lovely to talk to you this morning happy
new year um
this settlement dates back to 2009
doesn't it um and it basically says that
that she must not uh take further legal
action um
but the big question is of course does
this include prince andrew uh what are
your thoughts today
that's the question for the judge today
isn't it now this uh deal worth half a
million dollars signed in 2009 uh in
that uh virginia jeff ray
said that she promised to
release a quit satisfy and forever
discharge not just jeffrey epstein but
any other person or entity who could
have been included as a potential
defendant from all actions
claims variances trespasses damages
judgments executions demands whatsoever
in law and equity and this is the best
bit from the beginning of the world to
the day of this release which was in
2009
so this was a very very broad document
now does it apply to prince andrew was
he a potential defendant well he is a
defendant now so presumably he was
covered by exhibit a this this document
that
you're looking at now
on the other hand he wasn't referred to
by name in the agreement his lawyers say
he was a third-party beneficiary
and normally third parties can't enforce
the terms of a contract if they receive
only incidental benefits from it but
he's entitled to do so if he's an
intended third party benefit it didn't
refer to him by name that's what's
pointed out by virginia dufrese lawyers
but on the other hand her original claim
against epstein
said that she was required to be
sexually exploited by epstein's adult
male peers including royalty so it's on
that basis
that the prince's lawyers argue that
he's covered by this agreement
so if the judge decides that
he is covered by this agreement is that
the end for for mr frey that there is no
more potential of legal action
i'm sure there's a possibility
yes i i'm sure there's always an appeal
isn't there uh and and and another
chance but yes it's it's an important
point of course on the other hand um if
that argument is thrown out uh well the
duke of york has got other arguments he
says it can't be heard in new york
because she lives in australia she was
about the age of consent under new york
law at the time even the legislation
under which he was allowed to to bring
the claim against him it temporarily
reopened the statute of limitations
extended the time limit they say that's
unconstitutional so there are lots of
arguments on both sides as to whether
the claim should be allowed to go to a
hearing later this year if it gets that
far or it should be thrown out straight
away
if the hearing were to to be allowed to
go ahead and it's scheduled for sort of
september possibly at the earliest
would prince andrew have to attend
if the hearing goes ahead then it would
be difficult for him to argue his case
unless he was willing to give evidence
but i've always thought that this case
would settle at some point and i i
regard these
arguments that we're hearing today and
we'll be hearing in the future as
skirmishes to enable the two sides to be
able to assess and assert their relative
strengths um this is a civil case any
civil case can be settled the original
case uh that uh was brought against
jeffrey epstein was settled uh the
question is obviously how much money and
that depends on the strengths of the two
sides and how much they both want to
settle so
it would be uh interesting to see
whether there is going to be a hearing
later this year but obviously if there
isn't a deal then that's what will
happen
um and in terms of this civil case
how affected will it have been by the
the judgment and the verdict in the
gallan maxwell case which happened just
after christmas
it doesn't have a direct impact on this
does it but on the other hand it does
show uh you've seen the famous
photograph obviously of of the duke of
york of virginia giffrey and of gilain
maxwell together at her flat in london
and the fact that she is now a convicted
defendant that's the photograph there
the convicted uh defendant and uh is
facing a long prison sentence doesn't
really help his position does it but it
doesn't directly uh affect uh the the
case uh against him uh he was referred
to him passing in the criminal
proceedings against elaine maxwell but
he wasn't directly involved in it and
neither of course was virginia giffrey
she was not called to give evidence
which may or may not be seen as
significant
nonetheless this is all extremely
damaging for the prince's reputation
isn't it
it certainly is i mean it doesn't look
very attractive does it to take
advantage of a deal
when prince andrew wasn't directly
involved he certainly didn't contribute
to the half million dollars that epstein
paid to fray so
it's
taking advantage perhaps of of a deal
that his then friend no longer obviously
friend even before he killed himself
that his then friend reached so in terms
of publicity in terms of his reputation
it doesn't do much for him but obviously
if you're fighting a legal battle you
use all the tools at your disposal
indeed joshua rosenberg good to talk to
you thank you very much
let's get a quick look at the weather
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
well a stiff northerly wind will make it
feel really cold today it's mostly clear
dry and cold now with icy stretches in
the north but there are wintry showers
near north-facing coasts southern
england has more general patchy rain
cloud and rain there will mostly clear
from the northwest during the morning
but will linger over southeast england
elsewhere mostly dry and sunny
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
still come at the top of the hour on sky
news breakfast with more than a million
britons in south isolation and six nhs
trusts declaring critical incidents
we'll have more on the impact of omicron
[Music]